es importante precisar que obviamente
por todos los militares han aprovechado
todo el contexto de lo que vivimos en la
pandemia y por ende si bien han
condenado a eeuu la unión europea
otras naciones de asia han establecido
que es importante hablar de este tema
que potencialmente en el futuro se
pueden dar un bloqueo económico sin
embargo están atados un poco por todo lo
que están viviendo al interior de los
estados y los militares saben que es un
momento que pueden aprovechar muy bien
algo que preocupa además muchísimo es
todo el tema base que podría llevarse a
cabo esta semana unas manifestaciones
aún mayores de aquellas que se dieron en
1988 conocida como los cuatro bolsos es
decir 8 de agosto en 1988 ya con dos
personas fallecidas el corte de las
comunicaciones internet entre otros
temas pues es un escenario que es una
bomba de tiempo no solamente a nivel
asiático sino a nivel internacional y
recordemos que básicamente al interior
del mismo pues tenemos el caso de los
rohingyas esa etnia musulmana
implica un desarrollo fuerte señor todo
y estas posibles sanciones que está
estudiando la unión europea para imponer
a la junta militar que está gobernando
ahora de facto en mianmar qué efecto
tendrían y podrían ser de pronto un
primer paso para que otros actores
internacionales sigan el mismo camino
para presionar a los militares
eso se espera ya de por sí el líder
militar que ha dado este golpe de estado
se supone que podría hablar en los
próximos años algunos juicios en la
corte penal internacional dado que ha
sido él el líder y han maíz con todo el
tema base de la represión a los
rohingyas y esperaríamos por supuesto
que se dieran unas condenas adicionales
y que pudiera generar un efecto dominó
en todo lo que tiene que ver con este
golpe de estado y rápidamente porque
sanciones y no los canales diplomáticos
muy cierto precisamente porque como lo
que vemos es en mi amar desde hace
muchos años una diplomacia y una
democracia que ha estado en riesgo y que
no ha sido completamente ada es una de
las razones más fuertes que encontramos
en porque no se puede dar estos canales
base sino más la represión y la sanción
esa sería como la gran conclusión por el
momento alejandro godoy desde la ciudad
de bogotá muchas gracias por haber
explicado este tema para la audiencia de
francia 24